GMA's ginger Zee let us sit on her we
rehearse all as she goes from working
mom to belle of the ball the piece see
how that went but he's not the beef
ginger Zee and her Pro Val Chmerkovskiy
bring Belle and Gaston to the dance
floor tonight my feet still are the
worst they're so swollen
every morning I can hardly squeeze into
my heels to do da last week with
ballroom debut of her three-month-old
baby Adrienne and her hobby Ben it's a
different life being up close and
personal with handsome man like this my
husband has been so beyond supportive
he's like no Gomorrah go push he wants
me to do really well so it meant so much
change with the busy mom bouncing back
and forth between New York and LA Val is
sometimes on baby duty and there are
lots of candid mommy moments I haven't
pumped my boobs are full do you care if
I do it in the corner here the first
time for everything that she does I've
had a lot of great support from people
who are saying thank you for making it
so normal for making because that's what
they go through at work whether they're
in a ballroom or they're in you know a
boardroom there's no secret I feel like
it's like what every parent does you
just have to organize and do your best
at whatever you're doing right now